[Música]
las personas lesbianas gays bisexuales
trans y de género diverso sufren mayor
exclusión y discriminación cuando huyen
de sus países en busca de un refugio y
protección ante esta situación naciones
unidas insta garantizarles sus derechos
fundamentales
dondequiera que vivan los abusos contra
las personas lgtb y desplazadas pueden
verse en forma de violencia de género la
exclusión de los servicios esenciales
como un refugio y una vivienda segura y
adecuada asimismo se les margina de la
economía formal al bloquear les la
entrada al mercado de trabajo y
consecuentemente aumentando su riesgo a
la explotación sexual hoy vamos a ver
cuál es la situación de los migrantes y
refugiados de la población lgtb a
propósito del día internacional contra
la homofobia la transfobia y la bifobia
y para ello entonces quiero saludar a
nuestro segundo invitado del día ls
diego lucero coordinador del área de
ejercicio colectivo del centro de
derechos humanos fray matías córdoba
gracias diego por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 le pregunté
entonces la situación de esto antes de
la comunidad lgtb
muchas gracias con mucho gusto
saludarles
nosotras nos encontramos en tapachula
chiapas y lo que hemos observado en
estos 25 años de trabajo que tenemos
acompañando y promoviendo la defensa de
los derechos humanos de las personas en
contextos de movilidad pues hemos visto
que
siguen existiendo los desplazamientos
forzados y no planeados hacia las
personas de la diversidad es una de las
causas principales por las cuales se ven
obligadas a tener que dejar sus
comunidades de origen por una
orientación sexual y expresión sexual y
de género distinta a la
heteronormatividad
que en el tránsito pues muchas de las
personas que llegan a esta ciudad en
búsqueda de un lugar seguro para vivir
pues están experimentando también
diferentes violaciones a derechos
humanos
ha existido también muchas violaciones
sexuales por parte del crimen organizado
de las instituciones también del
personal de seguridad
quiénes
y les piden favores sexuales con tal de
poder acceder a servicios en cuanto pues
es obligación de los estados poder
garantizar que las personas que expresan
una diversidad sexual o una orientación
sexual distinta a la externa pues puedan
entrar y puedan garantizarles el derecho
a la protección internacional además de
todo esto pues hemos observado que las
violaciones por parte de las
instituciones también continúan en el
caso de las mujeres trans no hay un
reconocimiento de su expresión
organización sexual y de género
siguen llamándoles con sus nombres con
los cuales han sido explicadas en sus
actas de nacimiento e incluso pues las
personas vienen llegando a este lugar
poder para poder encontrar un lugar
seguro donde poder restablecer sus
proyectos de vida y se encuentran con
una política me la tortilla que lo que
le impide garantizar un goce de derechos
pues les continúa violentando tanto así
que muchas de las personas que quieren
llegar a solicitar el derecho a la
protección internacional pues son a la
estación migratoria a la siglo 21 50 en
tapachula y que es una de las más
grandes a nivel de latinoamérica y esta
estación migratoria pues tiene toda la
estructura carcelaria hemos visto que
las mujeres trans están puestas están
colocadas en espacios donde están los
hombres y pues eso les coloca en estado
de vulnerabilidad
muchísimo más por el hecho incluso de
que no se reconocen no hay un permiso
tampoco o sea no la ven tan con los
elementos para poder hacer y poder
visibilizar su expresión sexual y de
género ahora diego como trabajan ustedes
desde su organización para apoyar a
estas personas y también como hacen
digamos ese enlace con el gobierno
para llevar estas denuncias y para
tratar de que estos derechos no sigan
siendo vulnerados a las personas de la
comunidad tlgb ti
nosotros lo que estamos haciendo
constantemente pues es el monitoreo
observación y documentación de las
violaciones graves que experimentan las
personas para seguir haciendo la
incidencia política además de poder
seguir haciendo muchos comunicados en
donde estamos hablando sobre lo que las
personas se están comentando que
experimentan además en nuestro centro
pues contamos con un modelo de atención
que va desde la mirada de género desde
la mirada psico jurídica también y
promovemos muchos espacios de
participación colectiva porque creemos
que al estar con las personas toda
nuestra atención viene desde una mirada
también de educación popular para que en
conjunto podamos estar con ellas y poder
así crear redes de solidaridad y redes
de apoyo eso es lo que hacemos acá desde
desde el pre matías y pues estamos
constantemente en esta lucha con las
personas y desde las personas para que
podamos promover pues esta exigencia de
derechos en su opinión que tendrían que
hacer estos países de acogida o de
tránsito para
esta estadía de estas personas pues como
tiene que ser respetando todos sus
derechos
en realidad también en el discurso
institucional va mucho de comentar que
hoy en día se tiene una mirada de género
no y en realidad pues nos hemos
encontrado con personas que trabajan
para oficinas de gobierno en donde hay
alma nos han comentado que no saben cómo
poder acercarse a las personas de la
comunidad por ejemplo no saben cómo
dirigirse hacia hacia ellas
no hay un reconocimiento de estas
expresiones y orientaciones sexuales y
de género entonces qué es lo que estamos
exigiendo pues para empezar que se
reconozca que es un motivo principal del
desplazamiento forzado que están estas
personas y que se pueda también aprobar
una ley de identidad que permita que
ellas puedan expresarse de acuerdo pues
a su orientación sexual y de género
además qué
también en los procesos de las
solicitudes de la protección
internacional
hemos escuchado también de que al
parecer no se reconoce a un hombre gay
porque no se le nota o sea seguimos
siguen reproduciendo pues estas
prácticas machistas misóginas y en donde
pues están encasillados en donde pues
todo lo que tiene que prevalecer es a lo
heterosexual entonces esa la exigencia
que estamos haciendo que se pueda
reconocer que todas estas personas están
experimentando este tipo de violencias y
que todos los estados estados deben de
garantizar pues que las personas puedan
acceder como mínimo pues a derechos
básicos